hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to best luck now this is a
game or it's an early access demo of a
game that was announced during e3 and
supposedly it features a lot of
experimental qualities and a unique
style of gameplay every night I see a
girl in my dream Oh No why do I have
choices this is kind of like the opening
for a fire watch oddly enough this is
how that actually went by she seems sad
she seems lonely I mean I don't know why
she's in my dream and being all lonely
and sad but I guess I'll go with she
seems lonely she always points somewhere
where why should I care I mean why
should I care it's my dream I mean
unless this is some ethereal ethereal
message from the beyond why should I
care is there a reason that I should
care if I see her again tonight gotta
get some sleep okay a little ominous
what are you planning to do if you see
her again tonight murder her oh hi oh my
god hi oh this is not what I was
expecting
why do I have so many fans oh no those
aren't fans oh hi cleaning bed come back
later
what do you mean cleaning bad who's
cleaning my bed okay alrighty then ah
lovely let me go over here little idiot
Lee deep June 29th 2027 hey that's a day
after my birthday okay can't go out
there dude literally do hello-o
online dating notes found today oh [ __ ]
I'm so lonely all right then what else
am I supposed to do is my bed clean yet
no bed is ready going to okay okay
alright then you do that yeah we all
hide holy [ __ ] that was so scary
what's with your jiggly arm wait you got
such a wibblewobble arm why should I
care where you're pointing and also
who's [ __ ] horrifying I thought you
were about to possess my soul I thought
I had to run no I don't wanna I don't
wanna go where you're pointing me to you
jiggly leg lady alright fine I'll play
your game you weirdo huh
so stop popping your GUI lucky so pull
over my shoulders huh this it's weird
though wolf a whoopee wolf
what's happening where are we going oh
gosh I don't know okay Oh butterflies oh
I missed them they were really close to
my face and yet I missed them Oh No
oopsy poopsy I didn't mean Zee weensie
to do Zee woozy that okay excuse you the
hell is in these woods with me Oh what
is that oh hello
ah oh hi okay sorry can I help you are
you the one growling in here what's
going on is this another tree of
butterflies nope that's a tree of leaves
I should have known
alrighty then
uh okay I don't have to go to the
bathroom
oh hi okay that one doesn't work
hi hidey-hidey-ho whoa what is that all
about what's with the giant goose oh hi
okay excuse me I know my time I take
this one all right what happens if I
take this one oh that's so weird
[Music]
I'm opening a door who'd have thought
this would be even be remotely possible
and also why I love to music gotta like
the music music is cool all right the
doors open now I guess okay all right
then I'm down I don't know why I had to
walk through that door also were you
pointing at me
miss jello limbs okay all right then
cool great why where are you pointing me
what's with the books should I do
anything about those books
doodlee what the hell did you absorb the
knowledge of the books am i helping you
somehow doodly doodly doodly okay ah
you're getting a sort of Assembly of
ghostly particles ICF is working so let
me get all these in fill you up before I
actually I have to go somewhere else
yeah no one more should do it right just
a top you off I guess doodlee doodlee do
okay no more I mean it's more out here
but I don't if there's more glowy buy it
you know you're full up okay you're full
up so I'm gonna go where you're pointing
now cuz they got nothing better to do
with my life then follow your
instructions
wonder if it's preying on something
about my subconscious if I'm out in the
public area or the public area the real
world not the dream world and trying to
find a date little lonely got
follow a ghost girl inside my own brain
we must be close
we're approaching whoo so many options
knocking down like bowling pins baby woo
six whoo ah am I supposed to do these in
a certain order
ah three okay I know how this works I
got it you think I'm a fool you think I
can't count to six you think I can't get
to the furnace door huh that's right
dude
lupa dee boobity boo and skiddy oh I did
that thing oh hi
all right point me in the right
direction again ghost lady ah this int
way you don't need any more books do you
need a hoot hoot her up in the woods oh
I see a flashing pair of eyes Oh what is
that
I saw a flashing white something I don't
know if it was a pair of eyes or if I'm
going crazy I feel like I'm going crazy
alrighty then whatever you say ghost
lady jeez and how much farther do I need
to go for this ah ah that's a shift in
the winds oh hi hello who are you and
why are you okay ding dong
oh no oh hi oh okay well that's nice oh
it's gone now
[Music]
all righty then will things you surely
have turned hopeful oh hello
Oh Oh what is this is this a lovely
picnic that we had I gotta fill you back
up again man you keep emptying out I
just gotta make sure your your ectoplasm
levels are top-notch
I guess not sure okay so I got to go
over to those lanterns over there but
let me see if there's more goopy
depositories around here Skoosh Skoosh
Skoosh okay you're full up I think oh
that again took a dark turn all righty
then how about you know Oh ding dong
ding dong ding dong ding dong every door
is a [ __ ] lie this looks like our
first 100 little little little little
little wear yawn I see yeah ha ha
doodlee doodlee doodlee oh oh oh where
you go when where you go in where you go
in oh okay I see what you're doing I see
the game you're playing uh-huh
okay all right ah it's so weird it's
like it's like portals but not quite
they just have a completely different
fundamental concept going on here
oh I see you in the window you dick hole
I was going for that one and then you
screwed me you screwing screwer I will
show you the power of my memory yeah I
got you oh yeah I remember I would do
yeah that's what I wanted to do but then
you were just a big ol screw bag Hey
good thing we didn't have to do all
those hi again okay you're not exactly
startling anymore I don't know why
you're you lady in yellow when I got the
lady in red fall on me behind
we got cherished memories in that
library and you don't need to intrude on
him oh where we're going now
I don't know what the end goal of this
is it seems it's an interesting core
concept and that it's like in addition
to it being an experimental thing like
obviously it's doing a technical
demonstration of the doors but there has
to be something else here that's under
the surface you know what I mean there's
something else here that's not quite as
it's written there's a story being told
here about why this guy's seeing these
two different girls in his dreams
because even though it may be
minimalistic and I don't even have a
face but it seems obvious to me that
there are two separate girls in this
dream do I got to do it in the phases of
the Moon I think I got a ride ain't it
okay is this it oh boy something tells
me there's a sense of urgency here but I
know the order now yeah freakin douche
you douche bag come on come on okay
diddly diddly diddly diddly I know the
order now I know the order
hi again man this is a tumultuous mind
I've got inside my head what if this is
what everybody dreams but they never
remember Oh where's my ghost girl no
Stacey come back please
Stacey Stacey please oh where am I going
I'm wondering oh yo throws oh you Josh
oh god damn it
that is the price you pay when you play
technical demos
[Music]
damn muta alright so that is best luck I
really don't know what the story is all
about it's kind of hard to tell when
it's just an early version like this but
if I had to guess there's some element
of loss here some kind of repressed
memories going on in this guy's head and
that's why he's dreaming about these two
separate girls for as little as there
was there there is a lot of clues as to
what the story is about like with the
Chinese lanterns and the books and the
library and the artwork of meeting this
girl as a younger man and then growing
up lonely so I don't know what it means
who knows let me know what you think
down the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]